[Musik]
acht minuten hat marina netta in dieser
zeit muss sie den 85-jährigen versorgen
und das ganze dokumentieren
die altenpflegerin betreut kranke und
gebrechliche leute in ihren
privatwohnungen zeitdruck ist die
größtes problem
[Musik]
deutsch zu unterrichten ist ein
standbein von antje fenske
die multi jobberin gibt auch tanzkurse
und ton unterricht sonst kommt sie nicht
über die runden
[Musik]
die altenpflegerin trägt große
verantwortung für hilfsbedürftige
menschen
die seniorin braucht ihre tägliche
insulinspritze mobile altenpfleger gibt
es zu wenige ihrer arbeit ist aber
gefragter denn je
trotzdem verdient sie ein viertel
weniger als der durchschnittliche
arbeitnehmer in deutschland macht mich
manchmal wütend gerade wenn ich sehe wo
wenn andere berufsgruppen und streiken
und machen und tun die kriegen denn das
was sie durchsetzen wollen und bei uns
passiert gar nichts
das macht mich wütend dass wir so viel
tun für die gesellschaft und keiner
sieht die multi jobberin arbeitet seit
20 jahren in verschiedenen jobs
sie schaut sich ständig nach etwas neuem
um während ihr verdienst seit langem
stagniert steigt das einkommen der
wohlhabenden in deutschland deutlich an
klar also dass es ungerecht verteilt ist
das steht außer frage
ich mache mir darüber nicht so viele
gedanken ich komme auch mit wenig aus
deswegen ist das für mich nicht so ein
riesengroßes thema wenn ich mal ein
bisschen weniger geld habe dann kann ich
halt nicht in urlaub fliegen
[Musik]
die altenpflegerin musste auch schon mal
14 tage am stück arbeiten weil kollegen
fehlten alltag in einem beruf in dem sie
auch am wochenende und nachts schuften
muss heute hat sie keine schweren fälle
doch sie muss sich auch um todkranke
menschen kümmern trotz der großen auch
psychischen belastungen bekommt sie nur
wenig gesellschaftliche anerkennung
[Musik]
die multi jobberin bei ihrem abend shop
auch tanzunterricht tanz ist ihre
leidenschaft den sie auch beruflich
ausleben will auch wenn sie dafür nur
stundenweise bezahlt wird
trotz der vielen jobs kann sie kaum
etwas fürs alter zurücklegen
wie sieht es später mit der rente aus
darüber mache ich mir jetzt noch keine
gedanken weil ich eher der mensch bin
der eben hier im heute und jetzt lebt
[Musik]
die altenpflegerin lebt allein kann von
ihrem gehalt gerade so leben in berlin
in ihrer heimatstadt dort 50 schon
länger nach einer günstigeren wohnung
doch vergebens ich selber kann mir von
meinem gehalt nicht meine normale
wohnung gleis oder es gibt gar keine für
uns ja entweder muss man dafür viel geld
bezahlen oder man kriegt überhaupt keine
in der preislage so fängt ja schon an
ja und ich finde es sehr ungerecht
gerade bei sozialen berufen sollte man
die leute doch wertschätzen oder
überhaupt ein bisschen mehr fördern die
sich überhaupt für andere einsetzen ja
und da finde ich sollte viel viel
geändert werden unterwegs zum nächsten
termin die multi joggerin muss auch
abends und am wochenende ran
sie kommt mittlerweile damit klar hat
sich an dieses ungeregelte berufsleben
gewöhnt doch der wunsch nach einer
festanstellung wächst